la même moyenne messieurs ils étaient 24
avant de partir aux états unis au retour
de leur tournée des états unis sous le
plus grand chapiteau du monde ils
n'étaient plus que dix huit tellement
leur numéro était périlleux après un
séjour sous le grand cirque de moscou
ils se retrouvaient seulement à 12
ensuite après une tournée de nouveau sur
le continent américain en amérique
latine
ils se retrouvaient à 8 après la séjour
en afrique et en europe centrale
ils étaient six puis quatre ce sont les
frères ni l'os
je vous demande de bien vouloir les
applaudir ils sont là ce soir
et voici le premier des nuls hausse
voici porto
coc
ray ozzie dos
ouais mais non
frère il a fallu que le grand père
vienne en aide à ses petits fils voici
le vieil l'ancêtre hardy gbagbo dénonce
blâmer maso messieurs le premier numéro
qui va être réalisée devant vous est le
numéro qui a fait connaître les doses
dans le monde entier ce numéro
il consiste en une cascade extrêmement
dangereuse
ils ont appelé eux mêmes le bison
ouais ouais ouais ben
hop
vous avez ici assisté world offre en
quelque sorte puisque maintenant il me
semble pourtant pas encore au plat de
résistance le deuxième numéro qui va
être réalisée devant vous va exiger de
votre part une attention soutenue
en effet c'est un véritable numéro
fabuleux qui va suivre qui se fait au
moyen d'une chaise à partir de laquelle
ils vont élaborer une des plus
originales et plus fameuses pyramides
dans le monde
voici dans leur nouveau numéro les
nullos ça s'appelle la pyramide hausse
à
ouais
aïe
monsieur j'attire maintenant votre
attention sur le fait suivant le porteur
rico le porto rico pas grâce à sa sangle
abdominale en mer de boeuf faire de vous
un numéro de porter absolument
époustouflant il va au moyen d'une alter
invisible porter sur ses épaules deux de
ses frères
bah oui
las en guettant nerf de boeuf look et
l'ont fait pour tous d'avoir une vue
globale
ouais ouais ouais
évidemment difficile à réaliser et la
moindre erreur pourrait être fatale à
porto rico
voici maintenant un numéro qui les a
fait connaître en chine où ils ont
exécuté pour la première fois au monde
sur la pyramide de chine
ce numéro s'appelle et paulo il est
extrêmement dangereux puisqu'il est
constitué de plusieurs escalade surmonté
d'une double pirouette salto avant sur
les boules gauche du double porter qui
est à la base
ouais
non
cent vingt-six heures ils sont à cran
battre ils sont funambule ils sont
véliplanchiste mais ils sont aussi une
formation d'andy pauliste c'est
maintenant à un saut un terribles sautes
sur blanche que nous allons voir ce
numéro suivant qui s'appelle le béret
tos bastos je vous demande mesdames et
messieurs là encore la plus grande
attention car ce numéro nécessite de la
part des protagonistes une concentration
plus que d'ordinaire à la course aux
oeufs d'or
oui
ouais sont des choses qui arrivent
eusebio qui est le plus vieux nullos pas
réussi à se maintenir sur la chaise
porteuse mais beaucoup de courage il l'a
prouvé
car il a quand même fait de biaudos il
faut le préciser
j'ai dit on va vous montrer encore une
fois qu'il est le vétéran et qu'il a le
plus d'expérience en exécutant un seul
tome orthos qu'il est seul au monde à
pouvoir exécuter et qu'il est le seul à
avoir réalisé jusqu'ici sans la moindre
égratignure 1,07 à vous tous vos petits
fils vous regarde et aussi tous les
spectateurs du cirque
oh
lance le numéro est réussie bravo
maintenant vous remercions au chaleureux
applaudissements
bonsoir magdane bon sens mademoiselle
bonsoir monsieur